2015 hat die künstliche intelligenz
alpha goalie noch monate gebraucht um
einen menschen an der schwersten
strategiespiele überhaupt nämlich ko zu
schlagen jetzt schon gibt es die nächste
version alfa romeo und diese ki also
diese künstliche intelligenz ist
unglaublich viel mächtiger als ihre
vorgängerin alpha goalie sie brauchte
nur 36 stunden um besser zu werden wie
bitte also weil es so fielen beim
letzten video viel freude bereitet hat
wie ist die lage jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
immer mehr stimmen warnen vor der
rasanten entwicklung der künstlichen
intelligenz ki space ex kunde und tesla
inhaber ihnen macht befürchtet zitat die
größte bedrohung vor der wir als
zivilisation stehen physik genie stephen
hawking sagt die verdrängung des
menschen durch ki voraus und selbst
führende experten und expertinnen haben
sich mit einem wallenden brief an die
vereinten nationen gewandt in dem sie
eindringlich vor der entwicklung
autonomer waffen mit künstlicher
intelligenz war auf jeden fall ist ki
unkalkulierbar sie kann obwohl
intelligent rassistisch werden was ist
passiert sie entwickelt ein eigenleben
sodass sie abgeschaltet werden muss und
sie überflügelt uns inzwischen mit
leichtigkeit und das muss man bei alfa
romeo wirklich sagen die software ist so
optimiert worden dass sie wirklich fast
unbegreiflich stark geworden ist und das
obwohl sie im gegensatz zu ihrem
vorgänger überhaupt nicht mit bisherigen
kroatien gefüttert wurde alpha wo sie
musste also nicht mehr auf mehr als 2000
jahre geschichte des ko spiels
zurückschauen um es zu beherrschen
sondern es hat absolut ausgereicht 36
stunden gegen sich selbst zu spielen
nur 36 stunden dann war die software
einfach und sogar weltweit am besten
darin dieses spiel zu spielen
auch besser als ihre vorgängerin alpha
goalie sie besiegte ihre vorgängerin in
100 spielen zu null also 100 mal
gewonnen nun mal verloren alpha bulli
war von einem auf den anderen tag nicht
mehr weltweit am besten darin dieses
spiel zu spiel und es wird noch besser
alpha wo sie ist so viel besser dass sie
nur noch einen rechner mit vier
hochleistungs prozessoren benötigt bei
alfa goalie waren es mehrere mit
insgesamt 48 spezialchips also zwölfmal
mehr
und dabei wurde die software auch noch
super kreativ zitat sie erwarten nicht
nur fundamentale elemente der
menschlichen grundkenntnisse sondern
auch strategien die weit über die
spannbreite des traditionellen wissens
hinausgehen ja so entwickler david silva
und noch mal
es handelt sich um tausende jahre wo
wissen der menschheit die sich diese
maschine in ein paar stunden beigebracht
hat und dabei den menschen auch noch mit
leichtigkeit überflügelt hat es scheint
dass die skeptiker mit ihren
befürchtungen absolut recht
mit zwischen ihnen masken mark
zuckerberg von facebook ist ja darüber
ein heftiger streit entbrannt
wir haben ja darüber berichtet und es
gibt einen punkt den ich ganz wichtig
finde und dem nur wenige auf dem schirm
haben wir menschen sind einfach nicht
die schlauesten ihren mast sagt es so
zitat das größte hindernis die gefahren
von ki zu erkennen sind diejenigen die
von ihrer eigenen intelligenz so
überzeugt sind dass sie sich nicht
vorstellen können dass irgendjemand
dinge tun kann wie sie nicht können
ja und das ist ja immer so jeder mensch
hält sich für intelligent weil er sich
aufgrund seiner beschränkten intelligenz
unmöglich vorstellen kann dass
irgendetwas intelligenter sein kann als
er selbst alpha koserow hat es jetzt
bewiesen dass es doch geht ja wenn er
mehr zu diesem thema erfahren wollt und
zu allen anderen themen auf klicks um
dann lass mir hier ein abo da denn nur
dann verpasst er kein video und vor
allen dingen verpasst sie es nicht wenn
mir er mir ein
denn genau auf die glocke geht nämlich
nur dann erhaltet ihr nachrichten wenn
ein neues video online geht und
ansonsten würde ich das nächste video
empfehlen dass hier verlinkt ist da geht
es auch um die gefährlichkeit von
künstlicher intelligenz unbedingt
anschauen und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran